Hôm kài hôm thấy là sân nhận ông Thao Sien Sinoa chá đủ điều kiện sinh thà tụng chức thời hạn bảo tháng 6.
Hí đã chấp hàng đường 2 thần 3 mức án 1 năm.
Chà lời báo dưới 3,5 tụng tháng Sinoa chá trở biết,
bàn những định về khả năng sẽ giúp khoảng hóa đồng chính trị của ông Sau khi được phong thích.
Mà châu sàng ông nên dừng lại sau thời gian thu an.
Ông thao sinh chở về thấy là nằm anh in khuong trai mi ba, sau 1 mức lâm nâm xong lưu vong.
Và bị tuy nắng tám nâm tụng vì tụi lặng quên khi còn tại trước.
Sau đó, đường dạm số 1 năm theo lệ 1 xa hoàng ra,
quá trình cho bàn ngàn quân tự người chúi khi có thời gian điều chỉ tập in biệt.
Chức khi quay trở lại trạm theo phản quyết của to an tuy cao.
Theo khi định việc thà tụng chức thời hạn tự cá hội đồng ý quan xem sét và phê duyệt.
Zo ống thạm xin nắng thu an và bà phê thông tranh tự bị phê chất,
hỏi vị chi thu tụng, sau vị phản quy định về đạo đất công vụ.
Giờ tầm xin ao chá và được đánh xá là cónh vường nhất định trên chức chường.